ROB LEWORTHY: Hello,
welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Rob Leworthy.
And I'm very pleased to welcome
today, Zach Weinersmith, who
is the creator of "Saturday
Morning Breakfast Cereal."
Give me a cheer if we know
"Saturday Morning Breakfast
Cereal."
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
Good.
Oh, thank God for that.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Phew.
ROB LEWORTHY:
Author, entrepreneur,
internet celebrity--
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yes.
ROB LEWORTHY: we're going
with that-- and producer
of BAHFest!, which is
over for this weekend,
and we will talk
about in a little bit.
So first of all, Zach,
thanks for coming in.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Perhaps
you could tell us
about what you think "Saturday
Morning Breakfast Cereal" is
and how it came about.
Because I've wrote
down here, it started
in the heady days of 2002.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: 2002.
ROB LEWORTHY: It's a long
time ago in internet years.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
It's a comic.
It's the fourth-best
comic strip.
ROB LEWORTHY: As
voted for by who?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: In my head.
ROB LEWORTHY: Oh, OK.
Right.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
Yeah, it's, like, "XKCD,"
"The Oatmeal," "Penny Arcade,"
and then me.
ROB LEWORTHY: And then you.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: It's
about science and philosophy
and economics and everything.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
And how did it morph
over the years?
Because you have a
literature background.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yes, yes.
ROB LEWORTHY: And then you went
back to uni to study physics?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: I was taking
this from Wikipedia.
So I need to double
check those facts.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
You can use me as a citation.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah,
I will, a citation.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah, that's
all accurate information
from Wikipedia.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
So what took you back
to study physics later?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I was
working in Hollywood,
in the film business,
for the studio that
released "Sharknado," actually.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: It was 10
years before "Sharknado."
ROB LEWORTHY: Lot of facts then.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
That can go on Wikipedia too.
Yeah, I was just
working in film.
And it was awful and terrible
because everyone in Hollywood
should die.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Most
if them, not all of them.
And I hated it.
And I wanted to get out.
So I get to where my comics
were doing well enough that I
could quit my job.
And I did.
And then I found it was really
difficult to write ideas.
Because I was kind of happy.
You know?
You know, I was like,
23 and had savings.
It was weird.
This is a short version of it.
But I decided to go
back to university,
just to get some
stress into my life.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah.
That's good.
Nothing like deadline to really
make the creative juices flow.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: It's true.
It's true.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
And you do, SMBC,
has one comic a day,
which I think I
didn't realize that.
That's incredibly high turnover.
How do you find the
time or the Ideas?
Why set yourself the one-a-day
target, perhaps, rather than
three a week, say?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
I originally did it
because that's what they used to
do in the old comics business,
was one a day.
So I was just emulating.
But strategically, I
just try to read a lot.
You know?
And if you read old books,
you can steal all you want.
Because they're dead.
[LAUGHTER]
But no, I do try to read three
or four or five books a week,
and hard stuff.
ROB LEWORTHY: So you come
up with all your ideas.
And then I guess
the deadline forces
you to put something
out there every day,
rather than overthink it.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, absolutely.
ROB LEWORTHY: And
I think sometimes,
without those deadlines,
you know, that suffers,
and the deadlines slip.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, absolutely.
ROB LEWORTHY: And so when you
put all those ideas up on SMBC,
do you track what works,
what doesn't work?
Do you tweak the future
comics based on likes?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Actually,
my wife is a scientist.
And at some point,
when we have more time,
we want to do this
thing where we
try to analyze, to
see if we can predict
which jokes are successful.
Which is probably a bad idea.
ROB LEWORTHY: If anyone
wants a 20% project.
Then that's right here.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Because, actually,
I did this experiment
on myself once.
Because I thought I
could predict which jokes
would be successful.
Successful, meaning, retweets
or Facebook likes or something.
Or Google+, I mean.
ROB LEWORTHY: Sure, yeah.
We all use that an awful lot.
Absolutely.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I'm glad
this is being recorded.
Yeah, so I kept a diary,
which I would do a comic.
And then I would write
down whether I thought
it would be popular or not.
Not whether it was good,
just whether I thought
it would be popular.
And it turned out I had just
no predictive power at all.
I thought I would at
least kind of know.
Totally, I would say, this
won't do well, and it did fine.
So I apparently have
no predictive ability
for my own work.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
Well, that's good.
And I guess it keeps
it fresh and original.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Right, yeah.
I don't try to anticipate
what people want.
Because apparently, I can't.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
That works.
I think what I noticed on
your website was that you have
digital display advertising.
You've got Patreon.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Mhm.
ROB LEWORTHY: If you don't
know what Patreon is,
well, you can explain that.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: And you
have Kickstarter as well.
And then you sell
books in bookshops.
So I wondered of those
revenue streams, which works?
Which doesn't?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Sure.
ROB LEWORTHY: You were very
much experimenting with those,
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
My philosophy is it's good to
have a diverse set of revenue
streams.
Because if one suddenly
dies on you, you'll be OK.
So yeah, ad revenue is a
great source of revenue.
Except that there is a tendency,
when you serve as many ads
as we do, for the bad
stuff to leak through.
We've occasionally
had malware or you
know, buy-Russian-brides
stuff, which
we didn't feel too good about.
Or, like, vote Donald Trump,
which we feel even worse about.
But it's a consistent
source of revenue.
But actually, the downside to
ads is they're highly seasonal.
There's a lot of variation.
So you can't predict your
revenue stream, which
is bad for running a business.
Which, as Patreon, which
for those who don't know,
is essentially like a
subscription service
where you agree to
pay x dollars, like,
$1 a month to an artist, say.
And in exchange, you
get some token thing.
Like, in my case, you
get to see a comic early.
Or you get to see my
reading list or something,
little stuff.
But it means a lot
to the company.
Because a consistent revenue
source means we can be sure
we can employ
somebody and not have
to worry about making
enough return on investment
immediately.
ROB LEWORTHY: And I've
just turned my mic off.
So if you can't hear me
at the back, then wave.
So Kickstarter, as well,
you've had five or six projects
on Kickstarter.
And how have you seen that
grow and morph over the years?
And do you have the same people
coming back to you, and that?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, Kickstarter
has become a huge
part of book revenue.
And it's almost like it's weird.
Because we used to launch books.
And then we switched to
launching them on Kickstarter.
And it almost increased
sales in the opening
month like an order of
magnitude, which is bizarre.
Because it's the same product.
So humans, I don't--
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
So I mean, it does
allow some stuff.
It's a nice piece
of software in that
we can promise to modify the
book a little bit for people.
We can also service
people who want
to spend at different
levels more effectively.
But that doesn't explain
the order of magnitude.
There's some weird
Kickstarter magic juju.
ROB LEWORTHY: Interesting.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I
don't know what it is.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK,
and your latest one
is "Augie and the Green Knight".
I'm going to read it here,
"Augie and the Green Knight".
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I
have a new one out.
ROB LEWORTHY: "Augie
and the Green Knight."
ZACH WEINERSMITH: We just
wrapped up a new one.
That's a book called "Religion--
Ruining Everything Since 4004
BC."
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: And so with
"Augie and the Green Knight,"
this is your first
children's book?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yes.
Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: So
what was the spark
to writing a children's
book and stepping away
from adult comics?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Well, I'd
wanted to do it for a while.
We're also about to
have our first child.
But part of it was I have
this really guilty pleasure
for old Victorian
adventure novels,
like Henry Rider Haggard, and
Arthur Conan Doyle, and others.
But they're all really racist--
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: --and
sexist, and everything.
I was, like, can I give
these to my kid or something?
So I wanted to write a book
that had that tone to it,
but was not racist.
ROB LEWORTHY: And Augie
is a young girl who's
science loving, very nerdy.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah, yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah, this is
a gift for your daughter,
I imagine.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: In
a way, yeah, yeah.
It's something like that.
Yeah.
Has anyone read, there's
an old medieval romance
called going "Sir Gawain
and the Green Knight."
Maybe a few of you have read it.
ROB LEWORTHY: A few nods.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
And Tolkien did a version of it.
But this book is about a little
girl, who you kind of get
an explanation for the weird
events in the actual story,
via her exploits
manipulating things.
ROB LEWORTHY: Great.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Very good.
And it was fun to write.
And you got an
illustrator on board?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: So
that's the first time
you didn't illustrate
your own comics?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, it was great.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, maybe some of
you know, there's
a great French
cartoonist named Boulet.
And he agreed to do a series of
water colors as illustrations.
So that was actually amazing.
I didn't think we'd get him.
But he was excited to do it.
ROB LEWORTHY: Oh,
it's a beautiful book.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: It is.
We cost ourselves
a lot of profit
making the book look nice.
ROB LEWORTHY: Very good.
And this weekend,
you are over doing
BAHFest!, at Imperial College.
Tell us about BAHFest!
How that's been running
the stage for a few years?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, BAHFest!,
it's the festival of
bad ad hoc hypotheses,
which is as nerdy as it sounds.
And the basic idea is we
started it at MIT in 2013.
And it's, like,
the original show
was you come up with
the theory of evolution
that's clearly wrong.
But you substantiate
it very well.
So my keynote talk I gave the
first year was about how babies
evolved to be catapulted.
And I have a lot of
good evidence, actually.
And it explains why
babies are hairless.
But adults aren't.
And, like, babies are
more, like, cartilage-y--
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah,
no it makes sense.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: --so
they kind of bounce.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I even
talked to an aviation guy, who
had this theory that
babies have different load
balancing than adults do,
which keeps them stable.
ROB LEWORTHY: No, that
makes perfect sense.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah, yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I have
other lines of argument.
ROB LEWORTHY: I wish
your daughter well.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
She's past the
catapulting stage.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK, fine.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: But yes,
we're doing an evolution show
at Imperial tonight.
It's too late to buy tickets.
So I don't know why I'm
telling you about it.
ROB LEWORTHY: But it's not
too late for tomorrow's show,
I believe.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yes.
So we do another one.
The theme is big science.
Meaning, like, you
propose a mega project.
So my example-- which I
haven't done this talk yet
is-- I call it the
relativistic refrigerator.
And it takes food close
to the speed of light
so that it stays fresh.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: And
I haven't actually
calculated what it would cost,
say, to get a pie, to see.
But I think it'd be worth it.
ROB LEWORTHY: Very good.
And so you've done it a
couple of times in the States?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
We do a show in MIT, and
another in San Francisco,
and another in Seattle.
ROB LEWORTHY: Great.
Very good.
Well, I hope that goes well.
We're going to open
the floor to questions.
If you have a question, you
want to put your hand up?
One over There.
AUDIENCE: A lot of the stuff I
find in your cartoons reminds
me of the kind of thing
that Eliezer Yudkowsky used
to write about.
And I wondered if he or like
Scott Alexander, or anyone
from that crowd that
was an influence?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
I don't know if I'd
count him as an influence,
but I know Eliezer.
He's crazy.
I love him.
I've read a lot of his stuff.
And I stumbled upon his work.
And then I really enjoyed it.
But I only met him in the
last year or two, I guess.
I don't think I'd
call him an influence.
But he's been funny.
Actually, the kid's
book, he was one
of the early reviews we got.
He really liked it.
Because it's kind of
in his wheelhouse.
Because it's a little
girl who is super rational
about everything, kind of in
a fantasy world, telling it
it's wrong about everything.
ROB LEWORTHY: Who are your
other influences, if any?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Man.
ROB LEWORTHY: Or who inspired
you to start doing comics
when you were young?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
There's a cartoonist
named Glen Baxter,
who's probably nobody
has-- I see one person nodding.
Yeah, he's a surreal
single-panel cartoonist.
And he was the main one.
I don't really know.
I don't read a lot of comics.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
I'm not into them.
ROB LEWORTHY: No?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Were you
drawing from a very young age?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah, yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
Very good.
Question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: One of
the things I really
love about SMBC is the range of
ethnicities and relationships
that have [INAUDIBLE].
I've wondered, do you have a
program that's a random number
generator, telling you who you
should put in some situation
where it doesn't matter?
Or is it just wherever
the muse takes you,
or how does that work?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Every
engineer asks me that.
Do I have a random number
generator for ethnicity?
It's funny to me that that's
the obvious guess, I guess,
that I programmed it.
But no, I'm just at the
point of coloring it.
I'm throwing in slight
variations from this.
So I do have to
represent gingers,
perhaps you've noticed.
But no, I don't have a program.
Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Just shout out.
AUDIENCE: OK.
My favorite SMBC is
the one where you talk
about having various lifetimes.
But it takes nearly seven
years to master something.
I'm wondering if you follow
that advice yourself?
And if you do,
what are the things
you feel you've mastered
or become great at?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, I would like
to be able to follow
up more, actually.
I kind of stole
that idea, speaking
of stealing from the dead.
[? Robert ?] Hamming,
the computer scientist,
wrote a similar
thing, about how he
thought something
like an engineer
should switch field
every so often.
Like, 7 or 10 years.
I forget what he actually said.
But I really like that
idea, a general principle
of changing what you do.
As a pragmatic matter,
it's a little trickier.
Because I can't
stop doing comics.
Because I have a family
and they like food.
But I do kind of
switch what I'm doing.
Part of why I did a kids'
book was that motivation
to do something different.
I'm working on a
different book now,
that I can't say
too much about yet.
But actually, the
thing for me, now
that I'm trying to
switch into doing well,
is writing prose books
instead of comic stuff.
I'm still very much
interested in comics.
And it's also my livelihood.
But yeah, I'm trying
to get into that next.
I also have a previous lifetime,
trying to get a physics degree.
But I had to drop
out for comics.
And I'd like to get back
to that at some point.
But right now it's
a little too busy.
ROB LEWORTHY: How many years of
your degree, the second degree,
did you do?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I did,
I think, four semesters.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, I got just
to where I was about to
get to the good stuff.
And then I left.
ROB LEWORTHY: Very good.
And would you ever go back
to Hollywood, and screenplay
writing?
Is that still Something Or do
you think books and that medium
is what inspires you now?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I like books.
I'm not opposed to the film
as a medium or anything.
But the thing is, film is
extremely collaborative.
You can't just, like, go off
by yourself and make a movie.
And I am kind of an
anti-social jerk.
ROB LEWORTHY: A lone
wolf, if you will?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
Yeah, that's what I meant.
Yeah.
Lone wolf.
Yeah, so I'm really more
into comics and book
writing right now.
ROB LEWORTHY: Very good.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Do you tend to
plan your comics a long time
in advance?
Or do you wake up in the
morning and get back to work?
ROB LEWORTHY: How does
inspiration strike?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yes, well, in theory,
they are planned in advance.
I think I'll have to draw one
the night I get home, actually.
Yeah, it's got a little trickier
since we had a daughter for me
to get ahead on anything.
But I do write every day.
And I usually have a
backlog of a few drawn.
And I try to have
at least two weeks.
But right now I'm
getting pretty down
to a minimum,
between these shows.
And we did a bunch
of shows last winter.
So it's gotten a little tough.
But yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: What's
your favorite comic?
I guess you get
asked that a bit?
But is there one
that sticks as you
being particularly proud of?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Oh man, no.
I hate them all.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
I'm trying to think.
I did one, all I do is a
single panel, where there's
a kid in the back of the car.
And he says, mom,
dad I have ennui.
So they have to pull
over so he can make peace
with the universe.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: So
that's a good one.
I thought that was cute.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB LEWORTHY: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I
started reading SMBC
since I was in high school.
And a friend of
mine did as well.
And about a year into
it, my friend said,
Dude, do you know that if you
click the red button, what
will happen?
[LAUGHTER]
And so what's the deal
with the red button?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
The red button?
Well, for those of
you who don't know,
there's a little red button with
a bonus panel on each comic.
So there used to be
these websites, back
in the early days of the
internet, where you could
vote for your favorite comic.
And so I used it
as an inducement
to provide a bonus panel.
And then those
websites went away.
But people really
liked the bonus panel,
so I kept doing it.
And what's nice is
that people go through
and they read the comics.
And then they discover
the bonus panel later.
And then they have
to read them again.
[LAUGHTER]
And that's good for ad revenue.
ROB LEWORTHY: That's very smart.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Did anyone not
know about the red button here?
[LAUGHTER]
For the video, most of the
audience put their hands up.
So any more questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A lot of your
comics focus on couples,
or people being
in relationships.
How many, of a
percentage, do you
think got inspired by
your own experiences?
And what's your wife's
reaction to those comics
that you write
about relationships?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I would
say, almost none are actually
inspired by my real life.
I hate to disappoint.
But on the other hand, it would
be awful if that were true.
What was the second question?
AUDIENCE: What does your
wife think about those
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Oh, man.
What does she think?
Um--
ROB LEWORTHY: Does she wish
she were in more, then?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Oh, yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: Does she go,
oh, this will be funny.
You should put this in a comic.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Actually,
I've used her research twice.
But no, not too much.
She does read all
my comics before I
decide what I'm going to draw.
But that's about it.
Yeah, relatedly though,
one of the funny things
is you may have
noticed that I used
to do more comics where
the parents were borderline
abusive.
And since we had a kid, she
doesn't find them as funny.
[LAUGHTER]
I still do.
But I think I'll probably
do fewer just because she's,
like, this is awful.
I can't read this.
ROB LEWORTHY: Do you
ever feel, with SMBC,
you've created a box which
you have to stay within?
Or do you think you could push
it in one direction or another?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah,
I feel very fortunate
both because it's the
internet age of comics
so I can change format,
which I obviously do a lot.
But what's nice about
my format in particular,
is it is completely open ended.
So the only, I
suppose, restriction,
is it has to be a comic.
And I've even violated
that a few times.
And so no, I do.
I think if I had
kept, like, only doing
single-panel comics
or something,
it would eventually
have gotten restrictive.
But as it is now, it's not.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK, very good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One of
the comic formats
that I really appreciated from
you is these ones where you had
these fantastical situations.
And you iterate until
the level [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure you
know the ones I mean.
Where do you get
your views for those?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
I actually have one
of those going up maybe Sunday.
I'm not sure.
But I don't know, I
started doing them
just because they were fun.
But I think I started
doing more since I
got into reading economics.
Because a lot of
economics literature
is about, like, if you
tweak one little thing,
humans will just ruin it.
You know?
Call them perverse incentives.
You create a bad structure and
then everything goes to hell.
And so actually,
reading economics
has been very good
for discovering
ways in which you can
accidentally ruin the world.
So that's been a big
thing for me lately.
I think I've started
doing more since I
got into that literature.
There's one back there.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Your work doesn't
seem to have any recurring
characters, or at least no
obvious recurring characters.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that a
deliberate choice?
Have you ever been tempted
to introduce a character who
will recur, over and over?
ROB LEWORTHY: So in
case anyone didn't hear,
your work doesn't have
recurring characters in it.
Is that something
you've chosen to do?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I guess I
didn't think about it too much.
Part of what's nice about it
is every day is different.
I know with some people I
know, who do story comics,
one of the downsides is you're
halfway through a story,
and you decide you hate it.
And you're like, well, I've got
to do this for two more months.
But I have occasionally
been tempted.
And I don't have
recurring characters.
But I have lots of
recurring themes and stuff.
And in my head, it's
kind of the same people.
But no, that's part
of why, though, I
got into writing a kid's book.
Is it was a chance
to do something
a little more Narrative
but I don't know, maybe
one of these days I'll do
a story on the com page.
But I haven't had
the temptation yet.
AUDIENCE: How do you
determine whether
a particular comic
strip is actually not
that complicated and easy to
understand for a lot of people?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: What's
the level of nerdiness,
I suppose, that you
set in your comics?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, my rule of thumb
is only one Wikipedia
look up per comic.
I don't know, I mean, I
used to worry about that.
But everyone has access
to all the information
in the universe.
So I mean, you don't
want to overdo it.
Because eventually, people
will just get confused.
And there's some
stuff, like, I'd like
to do more literary references.
But most people, I don't
think, would go there with me.
Whereas the science
stuff is a little easier.
Because it's more generalized.
But if people don't know
a literary reference--
I keep trying to
do Hemingway jokes.
And no one appreciates them.
It's really terrible.
ROB LEWORTHY: With
that, do you think,
I might say that with
Patreon, and people
paying you for the
comics regardless
of where you go,
could you push it
in a more literary direction,
for example, and have people
come with you on that?
Or do you feel bound
by the science, nerdy?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
No, it's not that.
It's just, I mean, it's
still kind of the same game.
Because you still have to have
your audience come with you.
And also, Patreon is not
our main revenue source.
You know?
I have a friend
named Dave Kellet.
He does a comic
called "Sheldon."
And he does books
that are on themes.
And he did a
literature-themed book.
And he was, like, I couldn't
sell the damn thing.
But then he did a
book about pugs.
And he said, it
sold like cocaine.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah, I
would buy that book, yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
I think he's got
"Pugs 2" out now.
But literature is still
gathering dust in his closet.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK, very good.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In your
comics, you [INAUDIBLE]
receive angry
emails when you say,
[INAUDIBLE], or
things like that.
But first, why don't
you reply to them?
I sent something.
I never got a reply.
[LAUGHTER]
So how many do you
receive out of outrage?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
I actually don't
get that many angry emails.
It kind of sucks.
[LAUGHTER]
I've gotten little stuff.
I've got a guy who said, he
wanted to break my hands.
That was cool.
But no, I don't get too many.
I get, maybe, once a month I
get someone who is a little bit.
I think it helps to
have a nerdy audience.
Because I get more, like,
you-were-wrong stuff than
you're-a-bastard stuff.
Yeah, I think it was one of
the first times I went to MIT.
And I had six
freshmen around me,
telling me I didn't
understand quantum mechanics.
I don't know what I had done,
but I guess I was wrong.
But not too much hate mail.
Yeah, I kind of wish I got more.
It feels really good now and
then, to be mad at somebody
for being wrong.
ROB LEWORTHY: Do you think
if you did more religion,
you'd get more hate mail?
Is that the stuff?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I do
a pretty good amount.
ROB LEWORTHY: Also, this
is going on YouTube.
So if you want comments,
we can get you comments.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah,
I mean, I just released
a whole book of religion jokes.
And I haven't gotten much.
I did a rewritten Bible, the
whole thing, I rewrote it.
It's better.
ROB LEWORTHY: OK.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
It was too long.
ROB LEWORTHY: Much like the
actual Bible is too long.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, yeah, mine is, I
think, under 1,000 words.
But no, I don't.
I try.
I feel like I'm very,
very hateful person.
ROB LEWORTHY: Something to shoot
for in 2016, more trolling.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
That's true, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's sort of
a small thing, I guess.
But how far ahead are
you in writing comics?
Like, I can't imagine you're
like, going to go home,
tonight, as you said,
and write tomorrow?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: No,
but I'm pretty close.
I think I have two scripts
for when I get home.
But yeah, I do try
to be more ahead.
But the problem
becomes on a given day,
you want to select
your best script.
So if you work ahead, you're
selecting from a smaller set
than if you had waited.
So there's this
tension between waiting
until you've written more the
next day and not doing so.
It's almost bad if you
work too much ahead.
Because then you're,
like I said, picking
from a smaller set of options.
ROB LEWORTHY: Do you start
with a kind of single joke,
or a pun or plan on words?
Or kind of an idea that you
want to start writing about,
in the way that
people like jokes,
but just writing 100 ideas down
and one of them will be good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so one, I do
keep a sort of sheet of ideas.
These are just random thoughts.
But I try to, every
day, write at least
three potential comics.
And on a good day,
I try to write six.
But I don't always have time.
And at the end of the night,
I whittle it way down.
I think.
maybe one in six
gets selected, maybe.
ROB LEWORTHY: And
if somebody here
wanted to start
writing web comics,
the obvious advice is just
do it and getting online.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
ROB LEWORTHY: But beyond
that, any thoughts?
Has it got more competitive
over the last few years?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: A
lot more competitive.
Yeah.
The level of talent
these days is much higher
than it was when I started.
So there's this sort of
joke, when people ask what
to do when you get started.
And the answer is you
should start in 1998,
is what you should do.
But yeah, in terms
of getting started,
it's just, get started.
With comics, it's
kind of difficult.
Because it's a lot of work.
You have to write
and you have to draw.
And most people can't do
either, at least, at the outset.
But the other thing is I've
noticed most people can do OK
for maybe six weeks.
Because you're sort of
going through every joke
you've ever written, every
thought you ever had.
And you're putting
it in a comic.
And then it gets really hard.
And then you have to figure
out what you're doing.
I actually quit
a number of times
before I got to where I
was able to keep doing it.
And it was kind of just
learning about how to use
your brain well, I guess.
For me, I do a lot of reading.
Other people, I don't
know, travel a lot.
You have to do
something, though.
ROB LEWORTHY: And as we said,
those self-enforced deadlines
really--
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Makes a big difference.
ROB LEWORTHY: --forces
you to make something.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
Well, especially because if
you cartoon for a living,
you're completely freelance.
So you could just
Facebook-- Google+ all day.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Good.
A couple more questions, if any?
Yes?
I'll take this one
and then this one.
AUDIENCE: Hey, so Matthew
Inman, of "The Oatmeal",
had a lot of trouble
with lawsuits
and people stealing his
work, and things like that.
Is that something that
you've faced yourself?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
I mean, my stuff
gets stolen a lot.
And it gets a 9GAG
watermark on it.
And there's not much
I can do about it.
We haven't really pushed it.
I mean, I'm sure I could send a
cease and desist or something.
But the problem is,
it's all decentralized.
So it's, like, I say
9GAG took my content.
But actually, some
random internet person
took my content.
And so there's kind
of nothing you can do.
I wish they wouldn't
save them as JPGs though.
That's the part that
really irritated me.
[LAUGHTER]
But no.
And I actually think that
it's becoming less relevant.
So as long as people know
where to find your stuff,
I think you're fine.
You know, the way people
consume content has changed.
It used to be, like,
you'd go to my website.
Now, you got to Reddit.
And you go to social media.
You go to aggregators.
Most people don't go to
major websites as much.
Really, I'm sure that's
how my habits have changed.
It's mostly, like, Reddit.
And I go to a few
sites in particular.
So the point being,
the common wisdom
used to be to get people
to go to your main website,
so you can do ad revenue
and sell the merchandise.
And now, I think it's
becoming more, like,
you need people to just
know that you exist.
And then they'll say,
buy premium content
or become Patreon subscribers,
or that sort of thing.
So I worry less
because now I think,
as long as when 9GAG steals
my content, somewhere on it,
my URL is present.
And I'm probably getting a
reasonably good deal out of it.
Not that I'd encourage
people to re-post my content.
ROB LEWORTHY: Do you
have a Facebook presence?
Because I'm aware with YouTube,
there's a problem with people
re-posting videos on and
Facebook from YouTube,
and not being--
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah,
I've heard about that.
Yeah, we do have
a Facebook page.
And it's actually quite
good for business.
And I'm sure my stuff gets
reposted all the time.
But I started, I
resisted for a long time.
But now I put the
URL at the bottom.
For that reason, I
think that things
have just sort of changed.
And you have to do it now.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering about
how you produced your comics?
Do you start
sketching in pencil?
Do you go digital?
What do you do?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I used
to do pencil and ink.
And then I would scan.
But I finally switched
to digital, in 2013.
It's just, I think it saves at
least 50% time on the process.
And I was actually getting
hand issues, hand cramps,
from having to hand
font everything twice.
Because I had to pencil
it in and then ink it.
So yeah, I switched to digital,
not without misgivings.
Because there is something
nice about ink and paper.
There's no latency with reality.
You know?
But I think pretty much
everyone's digital now.
It's getting to the
point where paper
is kind of like a
charming way to do comics.
It's, like, the
old-fashioned way.
Yeah, oh, and I use
a Cintiq Tablet.
And Manga Studio is
the software I use.
AUDIENCE: How'd you
hear about SMBC.com?
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
What are they now?
Like, Sheffield
Muscle-Building Company?
I don't know.
SMBC.com, I think it's
just a squatter site.
There is no real Sheffield
Muscle-Building company,
or whatever it was.
I looked into what it would cost
me to buy it, a few years ago.
Because it's a
four-letter URL, which
you can't get them anymore.
And I think I felt
like an idiot because I
was like, I'm willing to
pay hundreds for this.
And they were like, we will not
sell this for under $25,000.
So I was like, there will
never be a time in my life
that I'm willing to pay
that much money for a URL.
ROB LEWORTHY: Was it
available when you started?
It might have been.
I don't know.
Well, no, it must have not been.
Because I would have
tried to get it, I think.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You talked about your
modernization a little bit,
you clearly have mixed
feelings about ads.
Do you use Ad Blocker?
And how do you respond
to people who do?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: I
don't use Ad Blocker.
But I don't have a problem
with people using it.
It's a problem.
It's not a problem unless
everybody starts using them.
So it's OK if there are
some people using it.
And I figure it depends
on people's behavior.
Because an individual's
contribution to my revenue
via ads is almost nothing.
Right?
It's, like, pennies.
But you make your money
because so many people come.
So what we try to do is say, if
you do use Ad Blocker, that's
totally fine.
But we encourage you
to say, go to Patreon
or buy a thing or something.
I was at a convention once.
And a guy ran up to
me, gave me a $5 bill
and said, I use Ad
Blocker, and then left.
[LAUGHTER]
And that was my ideal
reader experience.
That was awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
But no, again, my
usual view is it's
you can't change the
way consumers behave.
At least, I can't.
Maybe Google can.
You can subtly manipulate
them or something.
But I can't change the
way consumers behave.
So I try to just find out
what they want and deliver it.
But there's a
question right here.
AUDIENCE: As a
kid, were you ever
forced to write or draw
with your right hand?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: No.
No, I discovered I'm--
it's called-- mixed handed.
I'm not ambidextrous.
I just use a random
hand for each activity.
I play ping pong
with my right hand.
But I draw with my left.
Yeah, I was never forced.
That'd be awful.
ROB LEWORTHY: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Which Operating
System do you use?
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Chrome, OS.
I actually do use a Chromebook
for most of my stuff.
ROB LEWORTHY: They're very
good, I hear, so yeah.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
Yeah, wonderful.
But there's no Caps Lock.
ROB LEWORTHY: Is there not?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you
can configure it.
[LAUGHTER]
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah, but
other than that, it's great.
Yeah, I actually
do use a Chromebook
for most of my stuff.
But I just use Windows
10 for my home.
ROB LEWORTHY: There's no
sense of shame with that.
It's fine.
ZACH WEINERSMITH:
It's not the same.
It's the degradation.
[LAUGHTER]
ROB LEWORTHY: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Having written
the children's book now,
is it different?
How is it different to you
writing a book to nerds, say?
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Well, it is
a children's book for nerds.
Do any of you know like
cake-cutting problems
and number theory?
So there's this
class of problems.
It's called
cake-cutting, because you
know how your mom would
say, one person gets to cut
and one person gets to choose.
Because that's the solution
for a one-cut cake problem.
But it's, like, well, how
do you solve a three-cut?
And there are different
ways to go about this.
And there are different shapes.
And then what if
it's not homogeneous?
So I actually have
a joke about that
in the kids' book, which
is there's the Solomon
Solution for if two women
claim the same kid, what's
the solution?
So Solomon's solution is to
say, let's divide the baby.
And that will prove
out the real mother.
So I talked to a number
of theorists who thought,
as he put it, that
solution was a bit dicey.
[LAUGHTER]
Because it doesn't free
the false mother of her
desire to lie about it.
Like, in real life, she wouldn't
be, like, yeah, that's fine.
I mean, because that's
what happens in the story.
She's just like,
yeah, that's fine.
It's not really my kid.
So go ahead and chop
the child in half.
You know, you don't
think about it.
but it's not a great solution.
So but anyway, so I have this
part where the kid in the book
has to solve the Solomon
Problem for three mothers.
There's three moms who are
trying to claim one baby.
Because you can't
say, cut it in half.
Because what if one
of them gets 60%?
They might go for that?
[LAUGHTER]
And the best part, I
originally had a joke
about how I had
wanted to include
an appendix in the
book, explaining
the solution to the problem.
Because there is
a good solution.
Would y'all be
interested in that?
I could do that.
I'm totally blanking on
the name of the guy who
came up with this.
He's a famous game-theory
guy, and I just
can't remember his name.
His solution was
that you say, whoever
claims the baby gets it.
But if there's more
than one claimant,
The baby goes to an
expensive orphanage,
and everyone has to pay for it.
So now, you see,
the false mother
doesn't want to falsely claim.
Because she'll get stuck with
the bill for her non-kid.
Right?
The really cute part is,
I was talking to him.
And I was, like, well,
how would it work?
That's a two-claimant solution.
But how would it work for three?
And it turns out, it's
actually expandable.
Because there are
three claimants.
It's just you just have
three people paying
for the orphanage.
So the kid would get a
really good experience.
But then I came up
with what I think
is an original contribution
to mathematics,
which is what is the solution?
It is mothers go to infinity.
Because at some point, you can't
spend more on the orphanage.
And if you get infinity
moms, it goes to $0 per mom.
In which case, the problem of
a false mother claiming the mom
rears its head again.
I forget what my solution was.
I mean, you could solve it by
having an infinitely expanding
orphanage, until it gets
to the size of the universe
or something, I guess.
But hopefully it won't come up.
But anyway, so the point
being, it is a book for nerds.
There is a little appendix
section discussing
the Infinite Mom's Problem.
ROB LEWORTHY: We'll
leave it there and say,
thank you very much, Zach.
ZACH WEINERSMITH: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]